you know I have to congratulate you're
on the cover of shape magazine I have
never been on the cover of shape
magazine no one wants to put me on the
cover is this where you were you happy
with I mean obviously it's a great
photograph do you know like exactly
which one they're gonna choose to be the
cover no you don't you don't at all I
mean you take so many photos on the day
of course and then you really have no
idea what they're gonna choose and so
yeah I'd call it bootyful bootyful
yeah very nice it's a very nice shot how
are you that is going to be in the
checkout lines as you're eating yeah
what's it like for you you've got your
you've got your groceries here oh thank
you going through the line and mommy's
right there does that need an
explanation and yeah I'm cool with it of
course but yeah I think it'll be like
slightly awkward right also like I'm
very proud of it yeah yeah okay here's
my question and I'm very curious about
the modeling you started as a model at
what age about 17 me too yeah
why is that not plausible okay
but anyway so seventeen you started out
modeling yeah and you know it's it's
like starting out that young and you
were in places like Japan did I went to
Japan for the first time I actually went
there for many many years and I worked
and made made money to put myself self
through school but to be working as a
mom or as a model but it's it's crazy I
think if I cannot even imagine I wore I
were the craziest uniforms for for
nursing uniforms you know janitorial
uniforms I mean it was not the worst I
must say I shot an ad for Sony for some
electronic equipment and I was working
with a monkey that day and I will never
forget his name and you'll soon find out
his name was dodo johnny was a spider
monkey dodo Johnny hey dodo Shawn and
and in the ad was that he was gonna sit
on top of my head and it was gonna be
this cute he was wearing hat there's
gonna be this cute little photo and he
was acting up you know as sometimes
animals do yeah and they thought you
know what let's get him off her head
let's give him some fruit some passion
fruit some melons and oranges let's make
dodo Chon happy and about 30 minutes
later like okay dodo challenge ready to
go back to work and they place them on
my head and about five minutes later I
feel kind of like wiggling around a
little bit and then I feel the heat and
dodo dodo cha took a dump
they said I'm 15 pounds
put them on your head thinking you're
what they were doing watch this John in
half an hour was terrible and at that
time I actually was very professional
and here I was there was about seven or
eight Japanese people all very like
diligent and kind like with paper towel
and towels like cleaning the poopoo off
my head and back to work and they got
the photo and get back you know what let
me tell you something Michelle was when
when a monkey shits on your head that
put in a lock that's when it's time to
walk I went back to Japan and there was
the ad sitting in all the subways like
every time I got on the subway in Japan
there was dodo Chan on my on my realize
you got an interpreter clay it was an ad
for accident when you went back I
thought you said you saw dodo John sandy
and I we've worked with many shifts over
the years yes and they are tough yeah
and there was a a champ in New York that
punched me we worked with a bunch of
times and there was a husband and wife
and it was real it was like the sickest
most dysfunctional relationship and we
used this chimp all the time until one
time it was punching me so hard that I
had to request like can we not use this
chimp it's a housing yes we gave that
chimp a lot of money
you